58 % c'est selon la sp la proportion des
frappes aériennes réalisées au sahel
depuis le fin 2019 par des drones de
combat
plus spécifiquement des mg qda in reaper
fabriqué par l'américain général atomics
c'est cet appareil que vous pouvez voir
sur cette image du tarmac de la base
aérienne française 101 à niamey au niger
et et reaper c'est pour faucheuse en
france est parce que la guerre c'est
aussi une histoire d'armes avec des noms
qui en jette
bref 58% de frappe par drones c'est dire
la prépondérance de ces engins sur les
terrains d'opérations hors la france
l'une des premières puissances
militaires au monde reste encore
aujourd'hui sous-équipés en la matière
comme l'avait déclaré sans appel la cour
des comptes
l'an dernier alors que ces matériels
sont en augmentation dans la plupart des
forces armées la france a tardé malgré
la solidité de son industrie d'armement
à s'équiper du fait de projets ponctuels
conduit sans vision stratégique
cohérente sur le long terme
aujourd'hui encore malgré une
accélération de la politique
d'acquisitions le parc de drones
militaires français restent limités
comparativement à celui d'autres pays
comme le royaume uni et sur certains
segments vieillissant alors selon le
rapport du sénat l'hexagone serait tout
de même en train de corriger le tir bon
an mal an on apprend ainsi dans ce
document que les rippeurs devrait être
progressivement remplacé à compter de
2028 par de nouveaux appareils l'emporté
l'armée française accélère également
l'acquisition de mini et micro drones
des petits appareils légers de courte
portée qui seront dédiés à la
reconnaissance et au renseignement
sans compter les systèmes de défense
anti drones et compris pour la
protection du territoire national parce
qu'en france le nombre d'appareils
civils est passé de 400 mille à 2
millions et demi aujourd'hui en
provoquant au passage quelques sueurs
froides aux autorités par exemple
lorsque certains de ces engins ont été
aperçus en train de survoler des sites
sensibles comme ici il y a trois ans au
dessus de la centrale nucléaire du bugey
oui il s'agit bien d'un drone déguisé en
superman qu'il s'écrase contre l'édifice
il s'agissait d'une action de greenpeace
pour dénoncer les failles de sécurité
autour des sites nucléaires alors on se
demande tout de même si cela suffira à
la france à s'adapter aux conflits du
20e siècle
car comme l'indiquent le rapport la
guerre moderne c'est celle
drone plusieurs conflits récents non
seulement la guerre au haut karabagh en
2020 mais aussi les combats en libye en
septembre 2019 et la campagne turque
dans le nord de la syrie en mars 2020
ont été marqués par l'utilisation
massive de drones tactiques et de petits
drones selon des modes opératoires
nouveau pour pénétrer les défenses
solaires adverse et qui préfigure les
conflits de demain où les drones seront
omniprésents et le cas du haut karabagh
a été riche d'enseignements
cette guerre qui s'est déroulé à
l'automne dernier en transcaucasie entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan est l'un des
rares conflits conventionnels de haute
intensité
c'est à dire entre deux armées
régulières qui mobilise de très lourds
moyens en hommes qu'en matériel chars
d'assaut avions de combat artillerie
brouillage électronique réseaux sociaux
tout le dispositif militaire moderne a
été employée et notamment les drones
auquel bas coûts doit en partie sa
victoire ce qui a donné la supériorité
aux azerbaïdjanais lors de cette guerre
c'est l'utilisation de toute la gamme
des drones de l'engin tactique en appui
de frappe d'artillerie et aux troupes au
sol aux machines volantes à haute et
moyenne altitude pour effectuer des
missions de reconnaissance dans le cadre
d'une vraie campagne interarmées selon
les données fournies par l'institut
international de recherche sur la paix
de stockholm
les dépenses militaires mondiales n'ont
quasiment fait que croître depuis la fin
des années 90 avec un creux dû à la
crise de 2008 les nations semblent
anticiper un futur conflit de grande
ampleur et les drones n'y seront pas
étranger espérons que la france aura
terminé de se moderniser
l'objet de la guerre n'est pas de mourir
pour son pays mais de faire en sorte que
le d'en face meurent pour le sien
une phrase du général patton mort en 45
trois quarts de siècle plus tard à l'ère
des armes aériennes sans pilote
cette formule demeure plus que jamais
d'actualité